foreign
[Music]
here in this video we will be taking a
deeper look into the monsters and demons
of glyph barkers Hellraiser Universe
more specifically we will be discussing
the origins of the cinebites the biology
of theirs their types and also their
various Powers so let's get to it
let's start with the origins of these
demonic cinnabites these cinebites are
extra dimensional entities that have
been disfigured and indoctrinated into
Germanic people in The Labyrinth for all
eternity except for Angelique the
daughter of the demon deity called
Leviathan all cinebites were once human
these cinebites reside in hell and are
trapped there for all eternity and can
only be summoned by completing one of
the lemericans boxes which are puzzle
boxes that are promised Delights it is
at this time that a riff in time and
space will form that allows the cinebis
to enter the Earthly Realm as said
earlier all cinebytes except for one
were originally human but the first one
ever was a human that discovered the Box
millions of years ago and was thus
transformed into the engineer the first
cinnabide see there is this deity called
the Leviathan the god of hell and it
decides if an individual is worthy of
becoming a follower of his if so they
are brought to hell and are recreated in
the engineers transformation chamber so
the engineer acts as a catalyst for the
creation of new Sino bites which
includes a man named Elliot Spencer who
would become their leader called Pinhead
so let's take a deeper look in the
engineers chamber a human is captured
and the body is severely mutilated and
their blood is sucked out of their body
to be replaced with blue fluid the
operation utterly destroys the subject's
psyche to the point that the converted
victim is completely breath of memories
from their previous existence as a human
when completed the Warped caricature of
the actual person appears frequently
fitted with perversions of
characteristics of from their original
demeanor if the person is not yet deemed
worthy they will either be taken to hell
to spend all eternity in torment or be
destroyed on the spot the biology of
these demonic entities is completely
alien to life on Earth as they are a
mockery of their previous living forms
while humans require three things mainly
to live which is oxygen water and food
the synovites do not need any of those
they appear to possess most organs in
working condition even with mutilations
and heavy injury they are said to be in
constant pain and Thrive to further the
thresholds of sensation and pain these
cinebites are immune to any kind of
model weapons or attacks from humans
against them but can be killed by other
Supernatural entities such as other
synabites and higher entities and when
they die they revert back to the human
forms
so there are four types of Cinemas that
have been seen in the movies the first
is the engineer who appears as a
deformed and mutilated creature with no
similarity to humans self in appearance
the engineer appears to be more of a
being created to serve within the
Labyrinth itself the second type are the
normal cinnabides which are humanoid in
form despite having gashes tears and
mutilations all over their bodies
Pinhead Butterball the twins Etc are all
in this group they mostly wear leather
black leather and BDSM clothing except
for the latest movie this year which was
released which showed them to be all
naked
the third type is a single individual
which is called the chatteris bees and
is the pet hellhound of Pinhead this
creature is a hybrid form of a canine
animal that is reconfigured with human
flesh all over it
and the last type is the only one that
was originally not related to humans at
all this is Angelique who was the
daughter of the deity Leviathan and was
the demon princess of Hell Angelique
possessed a young woman's cops following
a sacrificial summoning ceremony and
came to Earth to stop the Elysium
configuration and when she failed her
Mission she summoned Pinhead to help her
but instead was turned into a cinnabide
by the high priest of hell
so now let's see the various powers of
the cinebites and also take a look at
some of their weaknesses and
disadvantages so because of their link
to hell and their own abnormal mutations
each cinnabide possesses a wide range of
supernatural abilities cinebites are
demonstrated to be capable of emerging
instantaneously in practically any area
and tracking down the person who
summoned them even across long distances
stronger ones like Pinhead have
demonstrated near Limitless powers to
the point that they can even change
people into cinebites upon death
all cinebis are experts in both pain and
pleasure masters of both physical and
psychic torment they also have
superhuman strength and superhuman
endurance and also durability
so although cinebis are very powerful
entities they do not have the freedom to
torture anyone nor do they have a free
will to rebel and do so they are all
Servants of the Leviathan and can only
act under strict guidelines of the
puzzle boxes they can only be summoned
to the Earthly plane by Blood and are
stuck to whatever location the victim is
in other weaknesses are holy artifacts
and even the lamentation box as well but
their main weakness is the Elysium
configuration which is a giant lemerican
box with the power to either destroy or
permanently trap the cinnabites within
their home Dimension through the use of
Light which was activated and did what
it was meant to in one of the movies
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video on the cinebites do hit the like
button for support and subscribe but
most of all smash that Bell icon for
regular updates on new videos right here
on this channel till the next one take
care fam